a long time ago in a galaxy far far away
a legendary Sith Lord was born from the
ashes of the defeated disgraced young
Anakin Skywalker Star Wars villain Darth
Vader is arguably the most famous bad
guy in film history but how well do you
really know the one-time Jedi who became
the dark sides most powerful asset he is
the untold story of Darth Vader it took
five men to play Vader the name most
commonly associated with Darth Vader is
James Earl Jones who provided the
menacing villain with his trademark
baritone voice but that's not Jones
inside the suit instead the more
physically imposing David Prowse for the
armor most of the time with fencer Bob
Anderson standing in for the lightsaber
duels and that iconic moment when he
takes his helmet off in Return of the
Jedi
that's the pasty face of veteran stage
actor Sebastian Shaw oh and one more guy
also contributed to the performance
sound artist Ben Burtt who created
Vader's trademark panting of a
microphone and a scuba tank regulator
the voice was a secret his voice work
may be iconic now but back in the day
the participation of James Earl Jones
was such a closely guarded secret even
the cast didn't know he was playing
Darth Vader so it came as a really big
surprise to David Prowse to guy inside
the suit when he learned his voice
wasn't going to be used after all he was
ticked off but George Lucas had a pretty
good reason for making the switch as
browses voice work was so pedestrian
Carrie Fisher called in Darth farmer
tearing it apart piece by piece you turn
those tapes playing the passengers in
this test I want them alive and the
Jones kept a secret for a long time not
only was he not credited on a new hope
or the Empire Strikes Back but he
straight-up denied that it was his voice
in the movies telling anyone who asks
that he thought it was the work of Bond
villain and 7up spokesman Jeffrey holder
whatever it
that makes seven I'm so refreshingly
different the other softens never had a
power never will orson welles almost
played Veda while James Earl Jones
eventually fests up to providing the
voice of Darth Vader there was a point
in time where someone else was
considered for the role instead Orson
Welles ah French Champagne in 2015
George Lucas revealed that he auditioned
two people for the role but once the
tapes were in the decision pretty much
made itself saying I knew the voice had
to be very very special and I had to
make a choice a choice that was a tough
choice but an easy choice really between
Orson Welles and James Earl Jones Jones
one good thing to considering Welles
died in 1985 while Jones has been able
to come back to voice Darth Vader again
and again for years I have one thing to
say to people like you I like Star Wars
too Vader's helmet was an afterthought
it's hard to believe but the iconic
black helmet Darth Vader wears
throughout the series wasn't even in the
original script which simply called for
a little respirator instead it was
artists Ralph McQuarrie who originally
devised the helmet which he intended to
be part of a spacesuit but the painting
was so striking that costume designer
John Malo
ran with it incorporating elements of
traditional samurai armor and naughty
helmets from World War 2 he has his own
castle
if you seem rogue one you might have
been surprised when the film suddenly
took an unexpected detour into Mordor
but that wasn't barad-dûr it was
actually bast Castle Darth Vader's
secret getaway sort of like an evil
fortress of solitude bass Castle has
actually appeared before in video games
and concept art has been floating around
since the late 70s with Ralph
McQuarrie's designs originally slated to
appear in Empire Strikes Back
there was one minor change in rogue one
though the location of bast castle has
seemingly been moved from the acid rain
planet on 4 June to the lava drenched
doom scape of Mustafa where Anakin had
his legs lopped off by obi-wan Kenobi
we're guessing real-estate prices were
reasonable Darth Vader's true identity
was an off-script secret at this point
there's probably not a single human
being on earth who doesn't know Darth
Vader is Luke Skywalker's dad whoa
nanjing who'da thought Darth Vader was
Luke Skywalker's father Thank You mr.
blow the picture for me but when the
Empire Strikes Back came Oh Vedas famous
revelation was shocking and one of the
best-kept secrets in the history of
cinema
knew I knowing that the real line was
going to be over dubbed in
post-production anyways by James Earl
Jones George Lucas wrote a fake line
into the script to make sure there was
no spoilers
when David Prowse read his line in the
climactic scene what he actually said
was obi-wan killed your father
when I first saw the dialogue that said
Luke I am your father
I said himself he's lying the only
person in the scene who actually knew
the truth was Mark Hamill who played
Luke Skywalker and even he was only told
minutes beforehand so he could react
with the appropriate level of anguish
through impossible the name is a clue or
is it
according to Lucas the name Darth Vader
as a secret meaning Darth is a variation
of dark and Vader is a variation of
father so it's basically dark father
that seems like it might be a clue to
the big secret that Vader would actually
turn out to be Luke's dad but skeptics
have pointed out that the whole Vader is
anakin thing wasn't added to the
storyline until well into the writing
process for the Empire Strikes Back
years after Vader was first named so is
Lucas full of it or did the name just
turn out to be a happy coincidence you
be the judge Vader may have been swiped
from Jack Kirby Lucas and the only
member of the Skywalker family whose
parentage may hold a shocking secret in
a case of art imitating life it turns
out that Darth Vader's real father might
not be George Lucas at all but rather
legendary comic book creator Jack Kirby
according to the book tales to astonish
during a fateful dinner meeting in the
early 1970s Kirby told Lucas about a
massive space opera he was planning
called the New Gods which features a
helmeted villain named Darkseid facing
off against a champion of light named
Orion who turns out to be Darkseid own
son and who struggles to overcome his
family's legacy of evil sound familiar
according to our meta zapper Kirby was
none too pleased with Star Wars healing
that Lucas had mine not just the New
Gods for inspiration but all of Kirby's
work he told my dad stuff like Darth
Vader was Doctor Doom and the force is
the source and that George Lucas ripped
him off well you know what they say if
you're gonna steal steal from the best
Vader had an apprentice it may come as a
surprise to learn that Darth Vader
himself had an apprentice given that the
SIF supposedly follow a really stupid
rule limiting them to only two members
out of time not to mention the fact
there has been no mention of Vader
having an apprentice in any of the
live-action films but as a simple
explanation he was his apprentice before
he became a bad guy and also she's from
the cartoons fans of Star Wars her Clone
Wars and Star Wars rebel course that
were talking about ahsoka tano nobody
knows exactly what sokka's final faces
but considering she was thrown out of
the Jedi Order before the purge it's
possible she may still be alive even in
present continuity could we see a pop up
in episode eight considering the Clone
Wars character saw Guerrero played a
major role in
a gwaan we wouldn't bet against it
thanks for watching click the loop icon
to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you're loved too